Якщо Урсулу фон дер Ляєн затвердять на посаді голови Єврокомісії,
вона загалом буде продовжувати політичний курс щодо Москви
нинішнього очільника Жан-Клода Юнкера,
але при цьому буде дотримуватися більш жорсткої лінії,
вважають міжнародні експерти.
Вона завжди була прихильницею зміцнення трансатлантичних зв'язків,
зокрема перебуваючи на посаді міністерки оборони ФРН.
Тому вона буде домагатися того, щоб на оборону виділялося 2% ВВП.
Вона зацікавлена ​​в посиленні санкцій проти Кремля.
Жан-Клод Юнкер відкидав це, посилаючись на роль Росії у Сирії.
Ймовірно, Урсула фон дер Ляєн буде проводити
більш жорстку політику щодо Москви.
Якщо Німеччина загалом займає доволі зважену позицію щодо Росії,
то Урсула фон дер Ляєн на цьому фоні виділяється.
У деяких ситуаціях вона відкрито критикувала Москву.
У Росії ж деякі експерти називають кандидатуру фон дер Ляєн
на посаду голови Єврокомісії одним з найгірших варіантів для Москви.
Вона не раз критикувала зовнішню політику Кремля.
У квітні 2018 року в інтерв'ю німецькій газеті Bild фон дер Ляєн заявила,
що Німеччині слід і далі дотримуватися жорсткого курсу
по відношенню до Москви.
А на конференції з безпеки в Берліні в листопаді 2018 року
фон дер Ляєн, коментуючи інцидент навколо Керченської протоки,
закликала Москву звільнити українських моряків
і забезпечити доступ міжнародних судів.
Не в останню чергу мова йде про велике досягнення цивілізації -
вирішувати міждержавні конфлікти
в рамках міжнародного права і правової держави.
Кремль в минулі роки порушив ці правила.
Так, Європа готова знову і знову протягувати руку Росії.
Це основоположний принцип.
Але Росія повинна визнати правила,
які ми встановлювали разом, і дотримуватися їх.
Урсула фон дер Ляєн - матір сімох дітей.
Колись її називали довіреною особою Анґели Меркель
і навіть її наступницею на посаді канцлерки Німеччини.
У грудні 2013 року вона очолила міністерство оборони ФРН.
Після подій в Криму фон дер Ляєн стала вимагати збільшити витрати на оборону.
Але її перебування на посаді голови міноборони дещо заплямувало
її до того бездоганну політичну репутацію -
через скандали навколо її відомства.
Приміром, серед військовослужбовців були виявлені праві екстремісти.
Також стало відомо про укладення однією з довірених осіб міністерки
аж надто дорогих контрактів з надання консалтингових послуг бундесверу.